quand on fait de la politique jean il fa
il faut apporter des solutions si tu dis
comme eric zemmour l'islam et
l'islamisme c'est la même chose et donc
en réalité il faut que les musulmans
renonce à la pratique de l'islam alors
je te demande quelles sont vos solutions
politiques vous proposez quoi parce que
moi je suis allé voir le programme
d'eric zemmour sur l'islam honnêtement
ces piteux il ya six petits points ça
fait un quart de page sur 70 pages du
programme donc je me dis faire de
l'islam le coeur de son projet politique
pour sortir un truc comme ça alors je
dis c'est pas sérieux vous allez c'est
vraiment ça c'est vraiment vous avez
surtaxer le programme de voilà donc
interdire le voile islamique hockey est
interdite à la construction de mosquées
imposante d'accord bon ok enfin il ya
six points alors moi je gère je n'entend
parler que de ça de la part d'eric
zemmour et j'ai un programme qui est
dérisoire c'est à dire sur u10 l'amt un
catalogue en finale mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que si vous considérez que
l'islam est un danger pour le pays alors
quelles sont vos propositions fermer les
mosquées expulser les musulmans retirer
la nationalité aux musulmans français
c'est quoi vos solutions politiques moi
je veux dire nous on a travaillé gens
nous on n'a pas fait ça d'accord on a
fait un vrai travail un travail sérieux
et un travail sérieux c'est autre chose
vois tu tu vois on a fait un projet de
loi un référendum sur l'immigration
voilà le référendum sur l'immigration
cette approche des doigts il est rédigé
où est le vôtre parce que vous voulez
faire un référendum je n'ai rien vu je
n'ai pas vu de projet de loi on a fait
un projet de loi contre liste de lutte
contre l'islamisme le projet de loi est
rédigée il ya plus qu à le voter ses
clés en main donc je pense qu'il faut
être un peu sérieux avec ses sujets et
arrêter de faire plaisir encore une fois
à des gens qui que vous je pense
induisait en erreur donc ni sam est une
religion la liberté religieuse en france
oblige à laisser les musulmans pouvoir
exercer leur foi l'islamisme c'est une
idéologie totalitaire et elle il faut la
combattre avec la dernière
hier des fermetés partout elle est
partout elle se cache partout elle est
financée par tous elle recrute ce faux
cette idéologie totalitaire qui va à
l'encontre de notre constitution elle il
faut évidemment la marianne comment tu
expliques que le mot islamisme n'existe
pas en arabe c'est un artefact
sémantique a été créé pour dédouaner
l'islam de sa frange intégristes
d'ailleurs c'est un effort qu'on consent
pour aucune autre religion
les juifs intégristes ont dit pas que
c'est des judaïste les chrétiens
intégristes ont dit pas que c'est des
christianiste ont dit des chrétiens
intégristes donc le l'islam c'est
l'islam c'est le coran d'ailleurs je
vais te faire lecture puisque tu ne
connais pas l'islam je vais te faire
lecture d'un verset du coran et en a 600
comme ça mais je vais te les épargnants
ne pas faire de la théologie il s'est
aussi dit que l'islam j'ai sur le mât
tible avec la république tu parles de
l'islam donc si tu connais pas l'islam
tu peux pas savoir s'il est compatible
avec la république ou pas il l'azinat
café au bétail est nassau fana salomon
kalou
je te traduit certes ceux qui ne croient
pas à nos au coran nous les brûlerons
bientôt dans le feu chaque fois que leur
peau auront été consumés nous leur
donnerons d'autres peaux en échange afin
qu'ils goûtent aux châtiments gens ça
c'est de l'islam ou de lys
l'agencé de l'islam ou lycées géante une
élection avec moi ma question lorsque ça
c'est de l'histoire ancienne et fassent
sérieux tu n'es pas sérieux parce que tu
sais pertinemment qu'il ya toute une
série de pays musulmans qui lutte contre
l'islamisme mais ils savent faire la
différence lutte contre l'abandon danis
la menthe et mis en lui par sarah el
islam is n'existe man u contre l'islam
et this